have you read Andy Weir's project Hail
Mary I have not no you're going to love
it like it is basically uh
almost answering that like how could
they not see us type of thing almost
where he creates this this incredible I
don't want to spoil anything but you
know um it's just this the sense that
like
we could have totally different
perspectives with with an alien race and
not even like consider that you know the
two of us are coexisting almost yeah I
don't want to spoil anything because
it's really really really worth the read
or Oh you mean a different perspective
like the aliens have a different
perspective than humans yeah like but we
just like we see with this visual light
yeah someone could see in x-ray et
cetera you know like and just the way we
even come to the same perspective like
looking and observing is just so
different fundamentally
that like we could I mean it's not quite
like that it's not like it's like oh
they were actually on the moon and we're
you know it's nothing like that but uh
but it's such a unique and incredible
story I think Andy Weir is one of the
the best science fiction writers I don't
I can't say that with much Authority
because I don't listen to much science
fiction
so 0 30. I really like Andy Weir's books
and that book is no different but that
sounds like I'm really worried about
this I was like uh I would really love
it I've uh differently I've been very
uh I've I've done a lot of reading in my
life but like the science fiction is one
of the things I've been really really
weak on I haven't really read much and I
just made more and more friends over the
years recently
um that say
that I absolutely must read some of
these things are you do you physically
read or do you do audio books while you
run and stuff uh well I I do both yeah
but physically I sadly don't it's a
Kindle right yeah yeah yeah yeah but uh
but while I run I also do uh so I do
both I do about
uh on a normal day especially now that
I've been really focused on on reading
it's about 60 Minutes of
reading on a Kindle and I wanted two
hours uh because I run about two hours
when I don't have like other stuff like
today I won't run uh so it's about three
hours so on average I would say it's
like two two and a half hours a day and
I read and audiobooks are just the same
they're a little slower but they're they
they can especially for the classics
they can capture some of the magic with
the deep voice usually with a British
accent I love it I also read that uh
listen to sorry that uh a book on
propulsion like two years ago I remember
but I remember that was extremely
definition yeah it was an issue by John
D Clark yeah
it was very difficult to listen oh I
yeah I see I don't read I listen while
I'm on road trips or running or stuff
like that too so I swear there's
probably 40 or like not 40 but there's
like eight minutes of we tried DMZ 15
yeah 13
bm412 rmnl mitral muscle hydrogen for
like
I swear it's multiple minutes of
explaining one trial on something
because there's just so many different
chemicals they try I don't know it's
it's it's almost a joke like I literally
audibly laughed out loud listening to it
because I'm like this is so ridiculous
I'm sure it makes sense reading it but
like listening to it is just hilarious
but it's great though